o que significa um robô para vocês e
vamos fazer um parêntese é óbvio que não
ia trazer fichinhas aqui pra frente
falando de tecnologia né eu ia trazer um
smartphone para muitas muitas pessoas
a primeira imagem que vem à mente quando
a gente fala em um sistema robótico é de
uma figura semelhante a um ser humano
uma figura que realiza tarefas humanas
do dia a dia nós mais tarefas com muito
mais precisão tarefas com algumas
características sobre humana é mais
inteligente ele é mais ele erra menos
ele é mais preciso naquilo que ele faz
isso talvez seja uma tentativa de
aproximar essa máquina do conceito que a
gente tem de vida e vejo que isso não é
novo é essa imagem que vocês estão vendo
uma imagem do autômato que o leonardo da
vinci desenrolar no renascimento que foi
transformada
nesse modelo que está exposto para
outras pessoas
o formato a imagem não tem nada a ver
o que interessa é a gente ter realmente
um dispositivo que seja mais preciso que
ele erre menos que a gente que ele
realize tarefas complexas que ele repita
coisas que são muito difíceis
o homem a palavra roubou na verdade ela
tem a sua origem bastante contestada
a maior parte dos das fontes ela sugere
que essa palavra vem de uma palavra de
origem checa chamada ro bota na verdade
com um consiste em trabalho forçado
o primeiro relato que se tem notícia do
uso dessa palavra de 1921 uma peça onde
exatamente a primeira figura que eu
mostrei pra vocês foi representada era
um autômato uma figura bem humanóide que
realizava substituir uma pessoa que não
podia trabalhar não podia fazer suas
tarefas do dia a dia evoluindo um
pouquinho nesse conceito o existe um
instituto americano em pizza chamado
robótica institute of america que define
os sistemas robóticos como um
manipulador que ele é reprogramável e
que ele tem umas algumas características
bem peculiares
ele move objetos ele realiza tarefas
complexas
mas ele tem uma característica bem
importante que tem tudo a ver com o que
eu vou falar hoje ele tem uma
característica de autonomia ou seja ele
toma as suas decisões baseado naquela
programação mas ele pode tomar decisões
sozinho
é muito importante a gente discutir essa
questão a gente fala dos sistemas
robóticos que são utilizados hoje de
forma comercial no mundo inteiro é
porque porque os robôs que são
utilizados pelo menos como cirurgiões
ainda eles ainda passam pelo filtro do
médico ainda quem decide quem toma
posição final no seu uso em relação aos
pacientes é o médico
isso me remonta uma história que é muito
divertida do nosso processo de
implementação no hospital de clínicas de
porto alegre do sistema robótico
depois de dois anos de discussão com as
diferentes áreas do hospital todo mundo
envolvido em enfermagem administração
engenharia
finalmente chegou a hora de nos
apresentarmos para a comunidade
acadêmica para demonstrar às pessoas
àquela nova ferramenta e três colegas do
instituto de informática da ufrgs
pediram para conhecer a ferramenta
robótica
nós fomos lá montamos a sala é chamei
todas as pessoas só vão ser bem precisos
vamos falar
eles foram ricken me conhece com a
quando eu realmente gosto uma tecnologia
de alguma coisa realmente me empolgo
então com essa empolgação que me é
peculiar comecei a falar do robô que ele
cinco vezes pelo menos mais preciso em
determinados movimentos que a mão humana
que ele tem mais graus de liberdade que
a visão é tridimensional que eu posso
fazer muitas cirurgias que tudo o que eu
faço
nesse dispositivo que é o dispositivo
que a gente tem no hospital de clínicas
ele é replicado do lado do paciente com
mais precisão com mais tecnologia e
daqui a pouco eu parei olhei para os
caras ele estava olhando para mim com
uma cara de incredulidade assim com
quase um desprezo
aí eu falei de errado pra esses caras aí
eu perguntei para ele se viu eu falei
alguma coisa errada do ponto de vista
técnico a isolar novamente sendo assim
não doutor é que isso está mostrando um
robô aí como assim
isso só está mostrando uma unidade de
telemann população à distância unidade
masters leite só um pouquinho
no mundo inteiro os caras chamam isso aí
de robô e vocês querendo ou não é como a
gente vai chamar aqui no hospital de
clínicas
essa dualidade na verdade entre
tecnologia precisam a funcionalidade e
características humanas que a gente viu
que começou lá no dia 20 ela persiste
até hoje
quando a gente vai falar de robô e na
medicina obviamente que isso não é
diferente
quando a gente fala do bem cuidar que
será que a gente quer dizer será que a
gente quer dizer tratar bem as doenças
utilizando um dispositivo mais preciso e
eu tratar melhor o câncer tratar melhor
a a doença cardíaca tratar melhor a
cirrose ou será que eu estou pensando em
outra coisa eu estou me referindo ao ato
humano de tomar conta das pessoas de
poder me conectar com a dor delas de
poder entender aquele momento de
fragilidade que elas estão passando e
por que não aumentar um pouco esse meu
cuidado e tentar cuidar da alma das
pessoas também será que o bem cuidar ele
se resume a termos robôs mais precisos
como esse robô que está aí que é um robô
que faz a função de acessos venosos que
ele é extremamente veloz faz super bem a
tarefa dele eu não sei o cara não me
parece muito feliz ali sendo funcionado
pelo roubo
ou será que a os sistemas robóticos
significa com essa aproximação e se é
que eles podem nos ajudar a chegar junto
ao paciente e ofertar algo a mais nesse
momento de carência nesse momento que o
paciente não precisa ser tratado apenas
como uma doença mas que ele precisa ser
entendido como alguém que tem seus
anseios têm seus medos e que naquele
momento precisa de um apoio além do
apoio técnico
bom os primeiros robôs na verdade eles
se basearam apenas na precisam apenas na
tecnologia os primeiros robôs robô
significa na verdade
11 adequação de instrumentos
desenvolvidos nos anos 80 para indústria
especialmente a indústria
automobilística essa máquina chamada
puma que é uma máquina que realiza
tarefas programadas e ele iniciou com a
neurocirurgia por algumas questões
óbvias a gente tinha uma área restrita a
calota craniana com a possibilidade de
exames de imagem bastante acurados
permitindo uma precisão submilimétrica
para fazer biópsia a evolução natural
dessa tecnologia foi pra fazer biópsia e
para fazer implantes em tecidos ósseos
que de novo aquela o tecido ósseo ele
permite uma estabilidade que faz com que
a precisão seja muito fácil de ser
utilizado no sistema robótico
mas o que fazer na minha área por
exemplo como pensar em cirurgia visceral
onde a respiração onde o movimento
intestinal vai fazer com que essa
estabilidade acaba com a precisão toda
que nós queremos é nessa hora que a
dualidade do comportamento humano ela
volta a gente falar dos sistemas de
tecnologia foi na guerra que a gente
conseguiu desenvolver um sistema que
hoje permite salvar muitas vidas
um dos centro do sistema de de americano
do exército existe um departamento
especial que promover o desenvolvimento
de um robô para se eleger ao qual era a
idéia dos caras era retirar o cirurgião
do campo de batalha que era muito caro a
vida do cirurgião lá no campo de batalha
e colocar ele a distância operando
manipulando instrumentos cirúrgicos à
distância e isso permitiu que a gente
conseguisse desenvolver os sistemas
cirúrgicos robóticos da maneira como
eles têm hoje o ciro já operando seja a
metros ou a muitos quilômetros de
distância daquele paciente ser uma idéia
em 4 de setembro de 2001 11 uma semana
antes da queda das torres gêmeas no
prédio do haiti em nova york que
senhores lembrar ele foi atingido pelos
escombros
um cirurgião em nova york operou através
de uma rede
de conexão internet dedicada com fibra
ótica contudo um paciente em estrasburgo
estava provado o conceito de cirurgia
intercontinental e pasme né
a tecnologia naquela época hoje a
conexão de internet era pior que do 4g
dos celulares que os senhores têm aí no
bolso então o desenvolvimento de
cirurgias mais complexas cada vez se
tornando possível através dessa
ferramenta robótica prova que se a gente
pegar esse nicho do da cirurgia robótica
se a gente pegar apenas o foco da
precisão o robô tem conseguido sem
atingir os seus objetivos
ele tem tornado cirurgias cada vez mais
complexas factíveis e eu não quis
devagar muito mais
o melhor ainda está por vir com a minha
miniaturização a nossa imaginação pode
ser o limite e não estranhem se a gente
em algum momento ficar sabendo de nano
robôs como é o que está representado na
figura atacando diretamente as células
malignas dentro da corrente sanguínea
não existe limite para o que a gente
pode fazer nesse tipo de tecnologia
sempre é bom lembrar que no modelo atual
ainda há ainda quem define todo esse e
se essa interface com o paciente é um
médico existe uma figura humana por trás
disso e que as decisões são tomadas
apenas por essa pessoa isso é uma coisa
que os pacientes freqüentemente pergunta
pra nós
apesar de crescente uso desses
instrumentos de precisão robóticos ele
ainda tem um fator bastante limitante no
mundo que é o custo para se ter uma
idéia existem apenas 31 sistemas
robóticos no brasil e quando nós
implementamos no hospital de clínicas de
porto alegre há quatro anos atrás nós
somos apenas o décimo sistema
então esse é um fator bem importante nós
somos o primeiro fora do eixo rio são
paulo
agora vamos mudar um pouco o nosso foco
é a gente pensar no bem cuidar daquela
primeira daquelas segunda maneira que eu
falei a gente tratar as pessoas como um
todo
entendendo que elas têm medo que elas
têm anseios que elas têm fraquezas como
é que os sistemas robóticos será que
eles podem nos auxiliar nesse tipo de
interação
a presença digital virtual ela já é uma
realidade em vários hospitais do mundo e
o fato do familiar ou do médico estar
presente ainda que não fisicamente tem
se mostrado uma ferramenta muito
interessante no tratamento de doenças
crônicas e para pacientes
institucionalizados cada roda por
exemplo é o que mostra a primeira classe
light a seleção e matthew evans ainda
teve um país pequenino é dar escala e
lojas também conseguiu o impacto em
situações menos complexas mas não menos
importante do ponto de saúde pública
como por exemplo tratar pessoas com
limitação de movimento ou menos o mesmo
tratar pessoas idosas que têm
dificuldade no seu cuidado
infelizmente a gente não tem dados
nacionais e vou usar alguns dados
americanos mas 10 mil pessoas por ano 1
por dia pelos estados unidos fazem 65
anos dessas estimam que 65% e 70% delas
vão necessitar de cuidados de enfermagem
a longo prazo o que vai gerar além de um
gasto astronômico de mais de 200 bilhões
de dólares há necessidade de pelo menos
6 milhões de novos cuidadores num prazo
curto de tempo
sistemas robóticos de cuidado aos
pacientes eles já estão disponíveis de
várias maneiras em diferentes cenários
com vários nomes mas se vocês observarem
a tentativa que é de tentar humanizar
se vocês observarem todas as figuras que
se banana com as quais esse sistema se
baseia ela se baseia em uma figura uma
noite na tentativa de mostrar para o
paciente
tentar afastar ele um pouquinho da idéia
de que ele está sendo tratado por uma
máquina e tentar mostrar para ele que
existe alguém olhando ele como um ser
completo não ser que está doente ou que
têm uma limitação mas uma pessoa que tem
a sua família que depois que se
recuperar aquele problema vai ter sua
atividade produtiva
o que é inegável seja qualquer o tipo de
definição que utilize para o robô seja
com um utilizando essa definição de que
ele é um instrumento de precisão que nos
torna sobre humanos no sentido que lhe
permite que eu faça coisas que não são
feitas
eu não consigo fazer assim o auxílio de
uma tecnologia ou se eu pensar como uma
tentativa de me aproximar das pessoas de
uma amizade poder tocá las de poder
cuidar las globalmente a tecnologia
robótica cada vez faz parte do nosso dia
de cada vez vai fazer mais
na verdade a gente tem que enxergar o
robô como um verdadeiro aliado como um
verdadeiro amigo nessa tarefa tão
importante que é homem cuidar das
pessoas
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]